lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
presentarte el concepto de
transformación en matemáticas la palabra
transformación en el lenguaje cotidiano
quiere decir que algo está cambiando que
algo se está transformando en otra cosa
entonces que podría significar en el
contexto matemático podría significar
que estamos tomando algo matemáticamente
y lo estamos transformando en otra cosa
matemáticamente y eso es exactamente lo
que es estamos hablando de que podemos
tomar un conjunto de coordenadas o de
puntos y transformarlos en otro conjunto
de coordenadas o de puntos por ejemplo
podemos tomar este cuadrilátero que se
encuentra aquí que es un conjunto de
puntos pero es un conjunto de puntos más
grande que los cuatro puntos de sus
vértices podríamos decir que es un
conjunto infinito de puntos todos los
puntos que forman este cuadrilátero
digamos el punto
0 - 4 forma parte de este cuadrilátero
así como una infinidad de puntos más y
podemos aplicar una transformación en
este cuadrilátero y por ejemplo primero
voy a hablar de una transformación que
es la traslación me refiero a que
podemos desplazar a este cuadrilátero en
una cierta cantidad de unidades en una
dirección y todos los puntos del
cuadrilátero se desplazarán en esa
dirección y la misma cantidad ahora voy
a utilizar la herramienta trasladar que
tenemos en los ejercicios de khan
academy y voy a trasladar este
cuadrilátero y lo voy a hacer tomando
cualquiera de sus vértices por ejemplo
voy a tomar este y voy a desplazar hacia
la derecha digamos dos unidades y todos
los puntos del cuadrilátero se desplazan
en la misma dirección y la misma
cantidad también podría
y trasladarlo digamos ahora lo hice una
unidad a la derecha y una hacia arriba y
todos los puntos del cuadrilátero se
trasladaron en la misma cantidad y la
misma dirección eso es a lo que se
refiere una traslación y existe un gran
número de transformaciones que podemos
aplicar a este objeto no nada más las
traslaciones y veamos voy a hacer otra
transformación por ejemplo aquí tengo el
cuadrilátero psd
y esta vez la transformación que vamos a
aplicar es una rotación veamos
yo puedo digamos en rotarlo a partir del
vértice d podría notarlo a partir de
cualquiera de sus vértices pero
utilizando la herramienta que tengo voy
a rotarlo bueno si comienzo aquí digamos
lo voy a rotar 90
y efectivamente eso es una rotación de
90 grados con respecto al vértice de y
bien este cuadrilátero que ahora se
encuentra aquí es el resultado de haber
transformado con una rotación de 90
grados al cuadrilátero original puedo
observar que todos los puntos son el
resultado de una rotación de 90 grados
es decir si yo tomo el vértice c ahora
corresponde a este vértice que está aquí
y está exactamente a 90 grados respecto
al punto de rotación lo mismo pasa con
este vértice b que es el que está aquí
corresponde este corresponde a este y
este el vértice que corresponde este que
está aquí decimos que hay un mapeo entre
cada uno de todos los puntos de este
cuadrilátero
con el que obtuvimos como resultado de
la transformación y bueno sólo una
referí en este caso a los puntos de los
vértices porque son los más fáciles de
observar y creo que es buen momento de
introducir la terminología es decir yo
empecé con un cuadrilátero este que está
aquí que es el psd
y después aplique una transformación que
en este caso con una rotación y lo que
obtuve este cuadrilátero que está aquí
le llamamos la imagen la imagen de la
transformación y la transformación en
este caso fue una rotación de 90 grados
en el sentido en contra de las
manecillas del reloj y bien pero yo
puedo rotar con respecto a cualquier
punto a ver vamos a deshacer esta
transformación muy bien y ahora por
ejemplo voy a rotar otra vez el
cuadrilátero pero esta vez a partir del
origen de nuestros ejes coordinados y lo
que estoy obteniendo ahora es otra
transformación y lo puedo rotar a partir
de cualquier punto que yo desee y bien
veamos otra transformación
y ahora vamos a hablar de otra
transformación que es la reflexión y la
reflexión es algo que está asociado a
algo que conocemos de nuestras vidas
como los reflejos en los espejos o en el
agua y la reflexión se hace a través de
una línea de déjame traer una línea
claro que podría hacer en reflexiones a
partir de cualquier línea pero déjame a
ver vamos a poner esta línea a ver en
este caso tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 si este es
un pentágono irregular y lo que yo voy a
hacer es reflejarlo a través de esta
línea que está aquí podríamos pensarlo
como si esta línea fuera un espejo y lo
que vamos a obtener es la imagen de esta
figura reflejada a través de esta línea
como un eje de simetría lo que vamos a
obtener es la imagen en el espejo de
esta figura y bien hagámoslo
observamos que obtuvimos una imagen
reflejada por ejemplo este punto que
está aquí se encuentra a la misma
distancia de esta línea que el punto
original que está aquí y a la misma
distancia pero del otro lado lo mismo
ocurre con cualquiera de los otros
puntos desde que está aquí arriba está a
la misma distancia que éste pero del
otro lado de la línea lo que tenemos es
una imagen reflejada de nuestro objeto
inicial y las transformaciones que hemos
realizado en estos ejemplos la
traslación la rotación y la reflexión se
les llama transformaciones rígidas y si
recuerdas la palabra rígido en el
lenguaje común se refiere a algo que no
se puede deformar que no se puede
escalar no podemos cambiar su tamaño no
podemos doblarlo a eso se refiere algo
rígido es decir algo que mantiene su
forma y si lo quisiéramos pensar
matemáticamente podríamos decir que las
longitud
y los ángulos se preservan es decir la
longitud de este segmento que está aquí
es la misma que está en el objeto
reflejado y lo mismo ocurre con los
ángulos este ángulo es igual a este los
ángulos y las longitudes se preservan y
lo mismo a ver regresemos a la
traslación lo mismo ocurre en este caso
como en los otros casos la forma se
mantiene así como las longitudes y los
ángulos y cuáles serían transformaciones
no rígidas las transformaciones no
rígidas por ejemplo sería que yo pudiera
tomar este objeto que está aquí y
hacerlo más grande o más pequeño o sea
crecer su escala o decrecer la en ese
caso los ángulos se preservarían pero la
longitud es no o por ejemplo que yo
pudiera tomar este punto y estirarlo de
manera que los demás puntos se mantienen
en su posición pero éste no y el
resultado sería una figura distorsionada
del original
eso definitivamente no es una
transformación rígida y este campo es
sumamente interesante por ejemplo si
utilizas programas de computadoras para
videojuegos en realidad lo que están
haciendo es una infinidad de
transformaciones algunas de ellas en dos
dimensiones otras de ellas en tres
dimensiones
de hecho los videojuegos realizan
infinidad de transformaciones con suerte
si profundizas más en las matemáticas
llegarás al campo que se llama el
álgebra lineal que trata de todas estas
transformaciones a un nivel más avanzado
de hecho los procesadores gráficos en
las computadoras a lo que se dedican es
a realizar infinidad de transformaciones
y es lo que te permite adentrarte en
estos mundos en tres dimensiones esto es
muy interesante